cage nba l'ancien ambassadeur de france
et essayiste bonsoir jaime bergman
bonsoir en irak sur rt france alors
cette démission du gouvernement qui est
tombée cet après midi une vraie surprise
pour vous aussi le grand connaisseur de
oui oui bien sûr ça a été inattendue
pour tout le monde
peut-être pas les intéresser bien sûr
certains disaient avec quelques rumeurs
bon c'est vrai que le poste de medvedev
était déjà je dirais pas sur un siège
éjectable mais déjà depuis deux trois
ans disais qu'un jour ça dure tellement
de temps il partira mais finalement il
pas partie et là effectivement il ya eu
une espèce d'accélération l'histoire
parce qu'il faut bien dire c'est une
véritable accélération d'histoire cette
manière et bien justement il a dit
vladimir poutine la russie maintenant
est assez mûr il a dit c'est intéressant
il n'y a plus de coup d'état
le caucase il ya plus d'un direction
elle est mûre pour entamer une plus
grande progression vers une démocratie
c'est intéressant donc pour moi c'est
une véritable étape il y avait un
pouvoir présidentiel fort qui cumulait
tous les pouvoirs c'est la condition de
il a dit maintenant il faut relâcher un
petit peu il faut donner plus de
pouvoirs à la douma et ce pouvoir il va
changer certains articles en viendra sur
le mandat présidentiel
maintenant la douma aura pour
responsabilité date de voter le choix du
produit ni c'est elle qui va le thé
alors faut savoir si une fois le premier
votée elle pourra entériner chaque mot
du gouvernement ces détails qu'on verra
dans les mois à venir ce avait discuté
mais là vraiment la douma qui était un
peu une chambre d'enregistrement va
devenir un organe plus politique
alors évidemment pour l'instant il n'y a
aucun souci pour le pouvoir
ils ont une majorité mais tout de même
c'est quand même plus qu'une nuance à
montrent que la russie maintenant elle
est beaucoup plus stable plus assuré et
poutine prépare finalement l'après
poutine pour entrer dans l'histoire
comme l'homme qui a stabilisé la russie
qu'il a unifié et qui lui fait
progresser dont le nom dans une voie
démocratique à la
bien sûr et donc qui devrait couper à
mon sens beaucoup de critiques en disant
c'est un régime autocratique
présidentielle donc c'est pour moi un
pas important et que je qualifierais
d'historique
alors on n'entend évidemment les
critiques certainement de certains
observateurs
toujours prompte à critiquer la russie
où il prépare la près peut-être pour s'y
remettre encore une fois quelle est
notre rêve il a dit mme lins aussi il
faut être très prudent de 24 c'est
encore long et 4 ans ce même plus qu'à
tromper que les élections ont lieu en
mai 2 mai alors il veut avoir les mains
libres et il veut avoir le choix de la
décision sur son successeur est ce qu'il
se représente a lui-même ou pas normal
on verra alors oui alors il ya un
article
je regardais je vais essayer l'article
81 ligne à trois qui dit il
il en a parlé on est sanctionné au
convoi réalité gentiment et ali
peut-être qu'ils font des choses justes
article cercle président ne peut pas
faire plus de deux mandats et demande à
ses 2 c'est pas successifs
donc on verra alors évidemment depuis
très longtemps des bauges d'état de deux
scénarios il pourrait être la
biélorussie pourrait s'allier la russie
serait président de biélorussie la
russie mais pour l'instant ça marche pas
mais disons que simplement il veut
élargir il veut montrer qu' il n'y a pas
que mes vnf bon medef le suit depuis
très longtemps il a été son chef de
cabinet à saint pétersbourg ou 90 vous
l'avez rappelé il a été vice premier
ministre entend déjà anc
on se souvient en 2007 avant d'être peu
près son successeur pour l'instant il
est
il a encore les bains libres et il veut
rééquilibrer le pouvoir
alors peut-être on peut dire un mot sur
le futur où l'actuel produits on va y
venir d'abord déjà su remettre vnf
déjà pourquoi cette décision alors on
sait que dmitri medvedev était aux
environs de 30 % dans les sondages il
avait perdu en popularité
c'est d'un étang c'est l'une des des
principales raisons je crois que est
dans son bon en dehors il a il a perdu
en notoriété
je crois à l'analyse que je fais par
rapport aux successeurs
il n'a pas été assez effectifs j'irai
pas c'est pas un homme assez fort qui a
su imposer un des décisions ici c'est la
tournée avec lumières pour il n'a fait
que c'est un peu ce que l'on peut lire
que poutine a dit écoutez il suffit pas
de parler il suffit pas de faire d'éclat
il faut il faut être proche des gens il
faut les satisfait il a montré en avait
parlé en décembre
bon il ya d'immenses succès sur la plus
extérieure mais il ya des inégalités il
ya les pauvretés il ya le problème
démographique est vraiment pratiquement
dramatique
donc il faut quelqu'un qui puisse qui
est effectif et peut-être que medvedev
là dessus il s'est relâché avec l'âge il
a tout bon c'est un pays extrêmement
compliqué il a perdu un petit peu 7,7
maestra cette capacité d'imposer des
décisions parfois impopulaires comme
l'âge de la retraite comme le système de
santé comme l'éducation et ainsi de
suite donc il a voulu amener du sang
neuf en quelque sorte et le sang neuf
donc on y vient ce nouveau premier
ministre là encore une surprise ou une
surprise parce que
il est peu connu bon par jean que
j'écoutais rang venant ici des
commentaires certains disaient ils
auraient pu nommer coudry d'alexis
koudrine qui est un vieil ami de poutine
qui a été d'ailleurs classé par le
financial times le meilleur ministre des
finances du monde est là et donc il
aurait été un bon candidat mais d'un
certain âge là il met du sang neuf
alors qui est monsieur michou chine par
ici la preuve c'est qu'il voulait
montrer que vous avez fait quoi musquin
et bien alors il est impressionnant on
regarde le wild il a un cerveau il va y
avoir une force intellectuelle
certains le qualifient j'ai entendu
c'est moi qu'il dit le technocrate le
plus efficace de la russie et le
financial times encore il a institué
on sait que les impôts dans tous les
pays du monde évidemment c'est monsieur
qui resterait il est à la tête du
système fédéral des impôts de mi 2010 il
resterait au dire du financial times qui
est très critique j'avais la russie
généralement le système fiscal des
robots un des plus efficaces du monde
chapeau parce que c'était pas facile de
collecter les impôts en russie et je
rappelle que le taux d'imposition pour
nous c'est un paradis c'est 13% pour le
monde
bon entre et donc c'est quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un qui est à la fois acceptable
pour le clan des siloviki kseur et
structures de force
c'est à dire le le fsb l'armée les
milices laumes
voilà et en même temps pour les libéraux
c'est à dire les économistes parce qu'il
a un profil qui est acceptable pour les
deux îles et il a il est docteur en
sciences économiques alors que médaille
était juriste il a commencé sa carrière
dans les ordinateurs dont les systèmes
complexes
il a travaillé dans le privé d'ailleurs
une société qui se relaient sur
lesquelles deutsche bank
donc vraiment il a un curé qui l'homme
très complexe et donc c'est un homme
efficace qui va qui va justement
et si vladimir poutine l'a nommé c'est
pour passer à une autre phase
justement ça sera ma dernière question
ce que le temps file à quoi doit-on
s'attendre comme changement avec cet
homme eh bien je crois qu'il va mettre
l'accent sur
le relèvement d'économie la démographie
le système social l'éducation tous les
problèmes pourront pour répondre aux
besoins de la société russe qui a quand
même souffert de la crise dont le taux
d'expansion économique est faible accord
trop faible et donc il faut que la
machine sociale économique et de plus de
rendement et donc il a donné les mains
de cette machine si vous passez
élimination un vrai technicien qui va
accélérer la la marche vers plus de
croissance plus d'égalité plus
d'efficacité dans tous les domaines
éducation santé infrastructures qui
devra composer également avec les
sanctions économiques internationales ça
on verra on verra pour l'instant ils ont
été reconduits on attend vous savez on
verra si l'évolution est bien en ukraine
il y avait un échange de présumer que
vous avez 840 le plus grand depuis le
début de la crise la guerre et donc si
vraiment ça évolue ce qu'entre celles
veut ils pourront être levés mais voyez
l'europe c'est quand même un mammouth
qui est tellement lent pour le mou voire
vraiment le pouce et de tous les côtés
quoi peut-être qu'il faut espérer
merci beaucoup aux jeunes berg d'avoir
été avec nous et ancien ambassadeur de
france également essayiste merci merci à
bout analyse sur les jours au
gouvernement et cette surprise
aujourd'hui que la démission de tous
bolcho pris au gouvernement russe merci
à vous bonsoir